what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here on the Lord's Day I
don't know what's wrong my [ __ ] can
blame worried about it as long as we
could do this one on one that's all that
matters understand me it's Sunday it's
the Lord's Day wash your [ __ ] powder
your balls it's all over but the
shouting you understand me we got a
couple great weeds fear this morning we
got [ __ ] Zeke banana oh gee over
there we got the [ __ ] Mayans look at
this [ __ ]
22 points 23 points all of them urban
trees right there in Studio City look at
this one here I don't even know what
this is called this is [ __ ] Zombo
weed right here understand me so we're
doing swinging dick and giving our
chopsticks on the Lord's Day you follow
me everybody else is laying around well
you know what you need to do
last week was last week this week is
this week and somebody swallowed some
[ __ ] juju juice anyway the [ __ ]
Beast is back together standing I had
him tucked away for a couple of weeks I
have three of these I got a big one a
medium little one just in case you know
I'm saying you're caught in an elevator
somewhere
oh [ __ ] me tremendous I didn't know what
that was I was something that was in the
drug cuz I got another 23 different
types of quality weeds in the drawer old
more the 25% why because I'm in town to
see the [ __ ] devil uh no
misunderstandings speaking about towns
New York City get ready I know a lot of
people in town with his Uncle Joe we
come in to [ __ ] seek and destroy
Gotham is already [ __ ] sold out if you
didn't get that tickets you [ __ ] up
now you gotta wait though Irvine two
weeks the night before Thanksgiving but
what are you gonna do that's what we're
doing here we're throwing [ __ ] heat
you understand me I got the toothpick of
death whereas we crawled in the street
the kabob of death you follow me I stood
up with no one this is my banana Jie I'm
gonna spar come here now we probably
wouldn't get ready watch some football
and a little brunch at the family [ __ ]
them make them wait understand me
uncle Joey's here that's all that
[ __ ] matters listen from the bottom
of my heart I'm very very grateful about
what you guys watch the degenerates and
the response listen if it wasn't for you
I wouldn't have enough expression if it
wasn't for you I wouldn't been on top of
my game and if it wasn't for you
[ __ ] I wouldn't be here so the
gratitude from the fat little bottom of
my [ __ ] heart goes out to you
[ __ ] cuz I love you if you know
anything about anything
you know I don't [ __ ] around I [ __ ]
love you but Joey what is this a [ __ ]
sermon drop some [ __ ] reefer smoke on
me and I'm saying let out the pedophile
smoke
ah the launch of your [ __ ] tremendous
now I'll go inside I'll do [ __ ] bas
Rudin's oxygen [ __ ] tube I'll do that
like [ __ ] 50 times oh I'm writing and
the lungs will be clean tip-top Magoo II
understand you want to be on top of your
game you gotta hang out with the good
people anyway I'm excited about New York
trust me I'm gonna get to see my family
I get to go to my grave Thursday the
first night is the 39th anniversary of
my mother's death so I'm flying in I'm
gonna write to the grave putting the
flowers down smoking a joint blowing
some [ __ ] smoke on a [ __ ]
tombstone and I'm loose you understand
me loose now we're gonna smoke a little
bit let's finish up this boat and then
want to smoke some of this [ __ ]
hybrid Maya here Mayans whatever the
[ __ ] it is I'm gonna be out right my
[ __ ] scooter all day
tremendous I love it when he goes in
your nostrils and it wakes up your
[ __ ] nose hairs this [ __ ] somebody
farts you prepared but that's it and
that's that name nothing special here
well Joey's here solo you know me I
don't need no [ __ ] 20 people around
me to show you who the [ __ ] I am Here I
am so long [ __ ] looking in
[ __ ] right here cuz I don't
give a [ __ ]
I'm 55 I'm still alive you how lucky I
am
what are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
I smoked a little mine now you know how
we do it
never a dull [ __ ] moment you
understand me you want Douglas get a day
job and hang out [ __ ] to your buddies
you want to run the [ __ ] house
you hang on uncle Joey you go for what
you want who gives a [ __ ] you set your
mark and you enforce it ain't nobody
gonna give it to you the Bluebird of
happiness ain't gonna knock and you're
going just hand you what you want you
gotta go out there and say I don't give
a [ __ ] jack whatever you put a fireman's
hat on like [ __ ] like that what's his
name [ __ ] didn't know anyway don't
really matter you put a fireman's hat on
I like this [ __ ] roll off you you dunk
your job your weave and before you know
it boom you lay the right hand and there
you walk ain't gonna stop you just let
them know I'm with you you're with me
and these [ __ ] want to be with
us you and uncle Joey baby the game
ain't stopping now
you're moving out moving or moving
together in unison
oh you're gonna show these [ __ ]
you gonna show these [ __ ] you
understand me
if uncle Joey could do it he's a [ __ ]
loser I could [ __ ] in the rule the world
actually you gotta be thinking I can
rule the world I can just walk around my
dick up 10 times creep people are
sucking who gives the [ __ ] you do 90
days they put your little list and you
won't have trick your tree there's no
big [ __ ] deal you save on candy I'm
saying anyway what I'm trying to say to
you is you got the world by the ball for
you kidding you sit and hit the press oh
my god you know what you gotta do what
the [ __ ] what you think
one more let's do one more there's the
best oh geez is the one that push [ __ ]
Cavanaugh over the top and I'm saying oh
this is beautiful here this is [ __ ]
tremendous emo you follow me
our cats will be ready for you my name
Juan and tip-top my boo ready to go then
you'll have another one Wednesday before
we land in New York why cuz that's how I
roll I do my things like I do if I got a
list already for the [ __ ] I've already
done ten things then what the Weight
Watchers that was gonna weed store I
went and got a [ __ ] blue breakfast
there I wrote with my wife and the baby
I watched man on fire can you imagine
waking up this morning I'm drinking
coughing them for not letting a man on
fire is on are you [ __ ] kidding me or
what an hour I'm right there I was ready
to stick up problems ass up somebody had
just stuff to find somebody at 7:00 in
the morning to stick a bomb up their ass
anyway Joey which with the chitter
chatter we got a spark here let's
[ __ ] smart
not really gonna do it's buckling like
kids in Africa flies all over them right
now wishing they could be doing a bonnet
with a understand me
stop woe is me woe is dick I get whoa
and that woe sucks my dick they know
what was me the only what was me is I
should have got my [ __ ] high school
diploma but who gives a [ __ ] that's a
completely different therapy session
let's fill up this thing one more time
and we'll do it now let you go go place
your back but do what you got to do let
me got to work with my bookie or do your
bookie I don't give a [ __ ] as long as
you have witnessed that's all that
matters to you as long as you're winning
that's all that matters to me once you
gotta go pay that cops up towards the
diner on Thursday you get on my nerves
you understand me may I made a decision
early huh I give it to the bookie I give
it to the call me and look out windows B
I chose to Colombian look at that
windows look where it got me
Jesus Christ he's [ __ ] move I don't
worry about the big dog homeboy some
little [ __ ] dog they won't shut the
[ __ ] up I say my daughter sometimes my
daughter gets gives me an Emmy
who the [ __ ] gave you the line of coke I
want to get some bad [ __ ] I'm gonna shut
the [ __ ] up for 10 hours
thing I should be doing right now Joey
smoke the [ __ ] ball what's the
problem don't go
nice nice it's not it's a good [ __ ]
game I'm going for spider got shot
Allegra but it's a new [ __ ] game the
[ __ ] game and said and that's that
you know how we do it I show up if the
lords they don't give a [ __ ] you pray
for your family have dinner with your
family to ask the most important thing
is your family Monday go stab somebody
in the neck 15 times it's nothing to do
with me yeah dinner with your family
that's the most important thing beside
that the park guests will be up here
beside that I'm being God from rocking
this [ __ ] weekend and that's it
I love you [ __ ] stay black
see you during the week